hi hello
um my name is adolf gracias astray and
i'm professor at the department of
microbiology
uh director of the global health and
emerging pathogens institute
at the akan school of medicine at mount
sinai and today i will be
presenting some of the data that we have
from our group on development of new
vaccines
and advanced treatments against covid19
all right so let's start first with
therapies
for coping 19 there are not so many
therapies that have been available
and and there is still a lot of problems
trying to
give something to people that will
reduce
the burden of the disease reduce
hospitalization reduce possibility of
having severe disease etc
there are some therapies that have been
approved
one of them is from decipher this is an
inhibitor of the viral rna-dependent
polymerase
but is not working 100
in terms of preventing severe disease
um there are some others that have been
approved for emergency use have not been
used in the clinic
such as the plasma from commercial
individuals or the existing monoclonal
antibodies
although there is some concerns that the
new variants may be
not be able to be neutralized by some of
them
and these are the ones that i mentioned
till now they are
treatments that reduce virus replication
these type of treatments they are more
important to be given earlier an
infection
because you want to stop the virus from
replicating early on
once that people develop severe symptoms
there is less remaining virus
replication most of the disease now is
being caused by an exacerbated
pathological response in the host
and therefore inhibitors of our
replication didn't work so well
what we need at this time is inhibitors
of
the disease itself of the symptoms of
the disease
and among the ones that have been used
uh is the one that is more popular is
dexamethasone
which is in immunosuppressive drug that
seems to
at least reduce uh some percentage
of uh mortality as well as
of uh time that the people are required
to be the hospital with ventilation
uh when uh treated with being used in
the hospital for people that start to
have severe symptoms
but there is a lot of steel that is
needed in this area
we don't have a really very good working
treatment
and therefore there is still a lot of
studies that have been conducting trying
to find
new treatments against kobe 19.
now the type of studies that we have
been involved
on and not only my lab but many of the
labs
they have to do with what is called drug
repurposing and drug repurposing is
based on the fact that there is a lot of
already existing drugs that have been
used in humans
or that have been using clinical trials
in humans
for which we know already some of the
properties of these drugs in terms of
for how long they stay in in the body
what concentrations have been achieved
in the body when they have been given to
people
what type of adverse events they are
giving to thank you
to people and these are some
information that we already have and
that if
among the drugs that are already uh
being used in humans against
some ailments that they don't need to be
even viral infection or that they have
been tried in clinical trials and then
we know already some of the properties
of this track system on this track there
is
one or several that allow
also for inhibition of our replication
these tracks can be deployed more
quickly
because we know already some of the
properties when they have been studied
to into people
and why a drug that is being used from a
different ailment
will make an impact in mass replication
well viruses they require to use host
factors to replicate
because they are parasites
and they require these host factors and
they require a lot of host factors there
are a lot of things that the virus means
and that's why they need to come into a
cell
and take many of the host factors that
they require in order to make copies of
themselves
now if among the host factors that the
virus requires there is
already a factor for which a particular
drug is being used already in humans for
some
other treatment some of the ailment
and yes happen to me that this track
inhibits the same host factor that the
virus requires for application
then this track will make an impact in
bios replication by inhibition
of this host factor so that's the idea
about drug purposing
now there are several ways how you can
try to find drugs among the
drugs that have been already been used
in humans or they are being used in
humans
one of them is screen all of them our
lab has decided to go through a little
bit more of a focused
assay in collaboration with many other
people
which is making some predictions about
what of the tracks that are around
uh and they are most likely to make an
impact in value replication so and i
will tell you a little bit later
uh in one second how we make these
predictions but once that we have these
predictions
uh then we we take these tracks and then
we test it for the ability of these
drugs or not to inhibit the virus
in tissue culture and if that
that allow us to find now some drugs
that
uh inhibit the virus in tissue culture
come from that the ones that are working
best
we try to use them uh in animal models
to see whether they make
a they have their applications in an
animal model
and move uh hopefully quickly into
clinical studies
uh received at the end would they make
an impact on the disease
so how we make these predictions so they
can we identify compounds that inhibit
host factors involving sources of pure
replication
among known human drugs and for that uh
we have been collaborating with
ucsf especially with the group of nema
krogan
which is is a person
uh it has a group that is interested in
protein protein interactions
and protein modifications and how these
shape
the different diseases including viral
diseases
and what he did very early on as soon as
the sequence of the saskatchewan ii
was posted online and knowing
that this was the causative agent of
commit 19
he cloned each individual viral protein
and caused by susceptible to a total of
29
proteins and then expressed them in
human cells separately
and then determined through
immunoprecipitation
and mass spectrometry the host proteins
that are interacting with each of these
are processes this is what is called
a virus host interactive map
that we can see here in the middle of
the slide
and what you can see is little dots red
dots that are
having a constellation of all the
other factors uh it's too small to be
able to read here but
it's sufficient to say that it's each
small red dot is one viral protein
and the constellation around are the
horse proteins that are interacting with
these viral proteins
and the idea is that if our protein is
interacting with host protein
it's likely between that because it
wants to use this horse protein to be
able to allow him to replicate
so we think that among these 332 protein
protein interactions map
there are there is an enrichment for
host proteins that are required for our
propagation
now is there any of these 332 proteins
is there any that we know that can be
inhibited by
one known uh human drug that is being
used uh for another type of treatment
that's where we come up with a total of
69 factors for which there are no drugs
that can be
inhibit these host factors that we found
interacting with our projects
now for now in a defined drugs we
collaborate with
kevan and brian also at ucsf uh
that's what they are they are chemical
bioform
bioinformatics that their mind um
the spectrum of drugs that have been
using humans from which ones they are
able to inhibit any of these factors
that interact with
uh with uh one of the products of
saskatchewan
and with that they identify 97 different
drugs
that we tested for inhibition of our
application
i mean my lab has been in my group chris
white together with
romell helene and lisa the ones that
have been looking to these compounds
that kevin and brian found
that are some evidence that they will
inhibit one of these
horse proteins that interact with one of
the viral proteins
now the acid that we use is a medium
throughput assay in which
we use light viruses subscribe to
we use a replication assay in
biocontainment
we see first cells that will support
replication in the beginning we use
the ones that we know early on that
supports well replication which have
been
sick cells which they come from african
green monkey
and then these these cells have been
seated into little wells
uh now we put in in these wells uh the
different drugs that we're gonna be
testing at different concentrations
in triplicate and then we infect them
with subscribe to within the amount of
viruses
that is around five viruses per
100 cells so you get a fraction
of only a percentage of the cells and
then the virus starts to propagate and
in 48 hours in the absence of any drug
the virus is infecting almost any cell
of the culture
now if there is a drug that inhibits
viral replication that is going to
reduce the number of infected cells and
that's what we measure
at the end at the end of 48 hours
we fix the cells we inactivate the virus
we take these these wells from the from
the bio containment
and then we measure the spend of our
replication in our group
by looking at the number of infected
cells using
staining infected cells with an antibody
against divided glucoprotein
uh and if we see that there is an impact
then we also determine the viruses that
have been produced in the supernatant to
see that actually there is an inhibition
of our replication
not only the number of virus infect
itself and we have done this uh
these assays uh together a or in
parallel
to uh with a if a different group that
is in this
buster olivier country stuff
that they have used a very similar assay
but
they use as measurable replication
viral array rna loads and
we have very convergent results which
actually give us confidence that what we
are seeing
is actually true inhibitors of our
replication
all right so here i'm going to show you
an example of how rendezvous it looks
like in this
assay so we use when decimal at
different concentrations
uh and then we look for the ability
of these different concentrations to
reduce the percentage of infected cells
at igneous open density we have 100
percent of infected cells
as we increase the concentration of
destiny in these wells
we are starting to see a drop in the in
the percentage of infected cells
which is depicted here by the solid line
and you can see
that around one micro molar
concentration
you get a almost complete inhibition
of viral replication of virus infected
cells
and in the line that is not solid
we perform at the same time in parallel
in non-infected cells
cytotoxicity studies you can see the
productivity is not cytotoxic
the cell is starting alive but it's a
good inhibitor of our replication
with um ic90 inhibitory concentration 90
around one micro molar which is what you
want to start with
with an inhibitor in order to see
whether they can impact this
this this concentration smallest better
even if it's
lower concentration
now um these in vitro cells in human
cells
t cells that are human that are they are
not infectable because they don't have
the receptor
cells but you can make them infectible
you just press the human ac2 receptor
for the virus
now in human cells predator is even
better it has 1990
of 24 nanomolar which is a very good one
and that's one of the reasons why
this is inhibitor and why it's being
used now in the clinic
it's a good inhibitor of our application
now we have tested all of these
compounds this is just an example of
some of the compounds that we have
tested and all the the
things that we have in total now with
different collaborators not only the
ones that we have
done with these studies in the
interaction but also some of the
collaborators we have tested more than
800
tracks and and from then approximately
10 they are able to inhibit lag
replication and a few of them they have
a very good
ability to inhibit viral application
amongst the most important inhibitors
that we found this way of our
replication
are compounds that are known to inhibit
translation of protein synthesis this
one of them subtyphine
is able to inhibit one factor host
factor involved in protein translation
eyf4a
and this factor is known to interact
with one of the var proteins so that's
one of the reasons why we use
phototaping
it has been used in clinical trials for
phase one and two clinical price for
treatment of cancer because cancer
if you inhibit protein synthesis this
that cancer cells will stop dividing
and it has a 1990 in terms of inhibition
of sask of 2 replication of 154
nanomolar so it's
quite good quite potent uh compound and
this is one of the ones that we probably
will continue
using it um in in clinical trials that
will start soon
uh now um all the translational
inhibitors that we have tried the attack
is a different factor which is this ef1a
is also involved in translation and is
also known to interact with
at least one of them are proteins and
among them we we test eternity
4 which has a very good ic19
we are talking about 10 nanomolar very
low concentration required for making an
impact of our replication
and ptdepsin also known as aplidine
is another compound that also targets
ey1a and has been
approved in australia for the treatment
of multiple myeloma
this one has a 99 even better of one
nanomolar is
very very important inhibitor which is
one of the things that you want to have
when you're looking in a track in these
acids
very important inhibitor for a drug that
has been already been infused in humans
and we know that
event with respect to treatment at least
of multiple myeloma
we see if you look to the to the
cytotoxic
data the ones in the discontinued line
it looks like these compounds they're a
little bit cytotoxic because you get
reduction to 50
of the cells but it's not that they are
killing 50 of the cells that have been
treated
it's because during the time of the acid
the cells double um
if in the absence of inhibitor but in
the presence of this inhibitor the cells
don't double they stay the same they
don't die but they don't double and then
at the end
of the experiment you compare them with
nutritive cells there is only 50 percent
of cells
but it's not because 50 percent have
been killed is because this 50
has not doubled to 100 percent so that
means that
perhaps we can also uh uh not have
cytotoxic effects where we we uh use
them
in vivo from the cells or at least
events
if the use of the right concentrations
for steam inhibiting bio replication
okay so these in videos cells now uh we
move
also to human cells to mean three t's
and here we're comparing noven density
uh with pitidepsin or apridine
and what you one can see is that the
ic90
of of proteodypse or
ablative in um 23t cells human cells
is sub nanomolar which is around
20 to 30 times more potent than the ic90
of when distributing the same cells for
inhibiting
the viral replication so it's more
important than the decibel
not only works also in human cells like
to need three t's which are these
supportive cells
but he also works in primary cell human
cells
these are here in the right corner
on on the top these are pneumocytes
uh human pneumocytes the ones that were
divided replicates
that that's the rabbit from pluto potent
him of ripotte and stem cells
and in this assay i have an suv is able
to inhibit very well at the
low concentration 10 nanomolar the
infection
uh by sars cop2 and at the
end we did what is called a time
tradition assay which is what's
seen here in the right bottom corner
in which we treat cells
before infection or after infection and
we see whether the inhibitor is still is
giving an impact on virus
infection and after even four hours
positive protection is able to reduce
viral replication
at the time that red decimate is unable
to uh
you need to treat early with rendezvous
to make it impact so it looks like in
these assays
uplining or ptodepsing is more potent
than brenda city but the important thing
is um what
what the protein does in people now um
pt lepsin
is is targeting ey1a but there is
always possibility that it's off-target
activities of of inhibitors perhaps
inhibiting bioreplication not by
inhibiting eyf1a
but by doing something that we don't
know that pt lexington is doing
well it turns to be that because
pre-dedepsin and these inhibitors of
by1a they have been used for treatment
of cancer
some cancers have developed resistance
to this drug
and this resistance is due to a mutation
in ey1a
that change one single amino acid a399
by b
and prevents binding of glutathione to
ey1a and then inhibition
now what we have done is we have made a
cell line
in which we have crispr edited ui 1a
to introduce this mutation uh a399b
and then we look whether the pglebsin is
still able or not to inhibit
bioreplication that's what we see
in the upper right corner in the upper
right corner we see
that in red cells that contains these
point mutations single point mutation
ey1a
now they are unable to be inhibited by
proteolypsin with respect to replication
of substance too what if we use redstone
in the same cell when the cell has no
problem because has a different target
so what these experiments demonstrate is
that the target for inhibition of our
replication
of pleated epsilon is indeed ef1n
reductive is being used so probably for
new inhibitors that we'll be using
in combination with one decimal so it's
always good to see what the new
inhibitors
are they um are synergising
or they have additive attacks or perhaps
antagonizing so they don't work
they they kill each other we predictive
it in the case of
updating or predicting we did
experiments with we combined different
decimate with pre-detection rapidly
which they are here samurais and in this
case what we have is a narrative effect
that means that one drug the two drugs
can be used
and not only that because it's negative
effect probably you need a little bit
less of each strike in order to make the
same
impact now that's it working people for
that we have done
uh some mouse studies mice are not being
infected at least with
the the source of two that they would be
circulating before variants came
and that's uh with the experiments that
we have done here is before the variance
um and for that we need to make we can
make mice
able to replicate the virus but you need
to do the tricks and the tricks is make
them to express the humanity too because
the mouse cc2
is not very good to allow replication of
stars of 2
in the mouse you can achieve that by
transducing mice in the in the in the
lung
with a adenovirus vector that expresses
human ec2
and five days later after this
transaction now the lung
cells of the mouse are expressing
hemoglobin c2 so you can challenge them
with subscribe too
um when you do that now sunscreen two
will replicate and replicates as
we can see here in the right two levels
around between 10 25 to 23 pfu per ml
at the tripos infection now we have
taken these mice and treated it with
applied in orbited epsilon orbiting
decimals different dolls
one mig per kick one single dose point
three mixed by three doses i compared
with progressive with 50 mix per kick
three doses
um and when we see that both for a
decimal
but importantly pgdexin at its low acid
small concentration
is able to reduce viral replication to
level that
some instances we can really we cannot
even detect viruses
in the lungs of these animals
the other system that we have used is
not a transduced mice
but a transgenic mice in this case these
are transgenic mice uh
they are available from jackson
laboratories that express human ec2
under the control of the keratinocyte
promoter k18
and in this case now because this this
results in better expression in
in a lot of cells of human hd2 the
replication of saskatchewan of three
sediments much much higher it goes to 10
to the 70 per ml
and when we did the same treatment here
at 0.3 mixed bacteria three times
we again were able to reduce
dramatically the replication of virus
indicating that
yes appealing of protecting is making an
impact on viral replication
in the lengths of the sunny influx of
this animal that's an also reduced
disease
for that we look to the lungs of these
animals and we see that in
untreated animals there is a lot of
inflammation both in the alveolar
and in the bronchia but when we treat
them there must be pt dempsey we see
very little uh inflammation has been
reduced a lot meaning that there is a
big reduction of disease renders it will
reduce inflammation but not as good as
pretty depressing
and in uninfected mice obviously there
is no inflammation
now what happens in human um glitter
epstein has been developed by a company
called pharma-mart
again for the treatment of myeloma but
their interest is also
in scene where the prototyping is able
to be used for the treatment of commit
19 they have conducted already phase one
two trials
that shows no severe adverse events and
potentially some
impact of our replication in coppic 19
patients and now they are going to start
basically clinical trials
uh they are already in clinical
trials.gov
been described which they will involve a
total of 600
participants that have been randomized
into
three groups uh with one group with one
dose of pity that's in the other group
with a different dose of congenital sin
and a control placebo uh all of them
will
receive obviously standard of care
different decimates from destiny
and the idea here is to look with it now
treatment with pretty depressing results
in less days of hospitalization of
people with
coping 19.
so in summary with respect to
antibiotics i show you how you can use
information about virus house protein
interactions in teractum
we have also used the phosphate proteome
i didn't presented here data but we have
some inhibitors also based on processes
that have been phosphorylated
and that provides a rational therapeutic
target for drug repurposing
how pity depsy which is inhibited of
eyf1a
has potential of two antiviral activity
both with vitronipo
and phase three clinical trials are
moving forward so hopefully they will
make as an impact
for the treatment of coping 19 in
patients
now the second part that i'm going to
talk is about vaccines i'm going to talk
about the vaccine that we are developing
here on mont sinai
which is based on the use of vectors is
called
newcastle disease virus
now uh in terms of covet 19 vaccines
there are many different strategies that
uh
that have been used and we know that
there are really some vaccines that are
quite successful and they've been used
all over the world with some more
percentage of vaccinated people in some
places that noticed
but very successful uh vaccines
the studies that have been tried to move
forward they are inactive they are all
the positive potential vaccine
strategies that we know of
inactivated viruses antenna viruses
protein subunits
viral vectors like the additive virus
vectors that there are several vaccines
now that have been used
around the world like the sputnik
vaccine the astrosenica vaccine
or the jnj vaccine uh genetic vaccines
among which ones they are names in
germany vaccines are the ones that have
been now
quite successful and in using different
parts of the world
this is the vaccines from moderna
i'm from biotech tyson uh but
there are some of the considerations
that we need to have with these vaccines
for protein vaccines or
activated vaccines the use of antibond
the use of nanoparticles which
have been used for protecting for
example the mrna vaccines to be able to
be delivered where they need to be
but perhaps also they are useful for
protein-saving vaccines
the rise of administration most of these
vaccines have been given intramuscularly
but the viruses
start inflection in the respiratory
mucosal so perhaps
if there will be some vaccines that are
being delivered more causally to the
to the respiratory mucosa they may have
a better efficacy preventing
not only disease but also infection and
and all of them they are based on the
surface and antigen
of the virus the spike protein and it's
believed that they are working by using
of neutralized antibodies
against the spike protein that prevents
virus from binding to the receptor
but perhaps there is some other cellular
immunity that is also contributing to
the success of some of these vaccines
now um the one that i'm going to present
is is one that we are developing again
here in
in the arkansas school of medicine at
monsana my group together with peter
palace emporium framer
is basically driven by the senior
postdoc in the
lab and it's based on newcastle disease
virus
expressing the spike protein of sasko2
now why this one and why we need the new
vaccine they are quite successful
already the ones that they are
well there are some things that we can
see when we consider that it perhaps is
still good
to try to develop uh new vaccines um
first of all there is no pre-existing
immunity in humans against this vector
while vector newcastle is virus with
this
virus from chicken as far as from alien
horse it does not infect a cause
disease mammalian post is able to infect
cells once expressed antigen and then
it's been
inhibited very quickly by innate
immunity
and also induce a very strong innate
immune response is very good
in order to induction of antibodies
because of that
so that's another advantage but the main
advantage is manufacturing manufacturing
only castle disease various vaccines
they have been used actually for uh
protecting chicken
against severe newcastle disease virus
disease and uh
they are using the this use the same
technology as we use for the production
of influenza vaccines meaning that there
is
a lot of possibility of production
because all the facilities that
have been used for production of flu
vaccine could be
used uh for production of this vaccine
of cognitive vaccine if it's successful
vaccine
so it can be made very quickly it can be
making large amounts it's very
cheap to make and this may make an
impact in terms of
accelerating the process of vaccination
especially in developing countries
now is this a a virus a
vaccine vector that is safe
and unfortunately we know of already
studies in humans with these viruses
that has been
has been now being developed as a
potential alpha the tumor treatment
and from these studies we know that it's
quite safe the use
of newcastle disease virus in human
now what what we do in order to make it
the vaccine vector for
uh coffee 19 is the genome of the virus
has
uh several viral proteins but then we
insert one more
gene in the genome of the virus and i've
called it also for
2s protein this one has been
modified to incorporate the cytoplasmic
and transmembrane domain
of one of the glycoproteins of newcastle
this is virus and with this we achieve
incorporation of the spike into the
various particles the new gaseous
various particles um these fires are
able to express
here's us in western blood spike at high
levels we use a version of a spike that
is highly stable
um prefusion so able to use the right
antibodies
uh that we want to use in order to
neutralize the virus
and if this can be producing eggs as i
mentioned and that you get
viruses that are decorated in the
outside with the spiked protein and also
when they get inside the cell
will express more spike protein
now these viruses can be used
inactivated
i'd like to use the same method of
inactivation of the flu vaccine
and they have also an advantage to
showing here that perhaps can be also
used in life
intranasally and that may represent us
an advantage if he's able to induce
much better causal immunity
so we have tested the vaccine
preclinically in multiple animal models
i'm going to just show you some of the
latest results with the hamster model
hamsters are susceptible of sarcophagi
infection
in contrast to mice and they have
mobility they develop
disease they replicate the virus to high
levels we have immunized
hamsters in this case they are ionized
with life you cancel this virus vaccine
internationally twice
and then challenge with suscop2 and what
one can see is that in
animals that have received controls
then then you get the body weight drop
due to susceptible infection but the
ones that have received
the virus expressing what we call exa
pro spike exa pro is stabilized from
the spike they are all protected against
disease
measured by body weight and um they are
also protected from
a replication of the virus so if we look
to the levels of our replication that
they too
in lungs the left uh
the the right lung lobe or the upper
right
lung lobe what we see is that there is
no
detectable virus at day two while they
state to the seventh
pfu in the control mice at day five
is the known pfu what is still around 10
35
pfu in the control mice and not only
protects from
infection in the lung it also protects
from infection in the nose which is what
is here
down at day two in nasal washes
there is only one hamster that has some
level of replication which is lower
than the one that is happening the
controls and at d5 also there is
no measured parallel replica device in
this
vaccinated hamsters so it looks quite
promising in animal models
uh now we have been now starting
phase one clinical trials with the
collaboration of the governments of
vietnam
and thailand and we are also expected to
have very soon
phase one clinical trials started in
brazil
in mexico and also here in the united
states
we have been lucky to have help from
different governments
like the government of vietnam or the
government of thailand these countries
are very interested in this type of
vaccines because they have manufacturing
conditions for the influenza virus
vaccine so they can use this for
manufacture
locally this new castle this is virus
vaccine
and they have started as i mentioned
facebook clinical trials in vietnam in
march 15.
as well as in thailand in march 32.
until now they are going fine
individuals that have received the
vaccine that have not developed similar
twice events
so that looks well um his question of
looking down with the high cholesteric
it is with the spiritual antibody
production if he's asymmetric as he
tells the promise in animal models you
never know
and see whether it can be then used as a
new vaccine against copper 19 that is
more easy to produce
and therefore they will be more fast in
terms of vaccination in the world
i have a few more slides that just treat
the issue of variance which i think is
important because everybody is worried
about variance
now my lab at many different labs in the
world now have tested
whether this serum for vaccinated
individuals
and from infected individuals is still
able to neutralize
the new variants and the variants that
are of concern they contain
either of two mutations one is what is
called the nailing mutation which is the
mutation in the rna binding domain
and 501 y that uh makes the virus more
permissible but also could make it
evade neutralize an antibodies because
the transient deposits
are against the to the receptor binding
domain when we test this variant we take
with
vaccine syrup from vaccinated people or
feel of compilation from infected people
we don't see
when we compare the whole variant to the
new variant
we don't see a drop in tiles that means
that this m501 white mutation
perhaps makes the virus more
transmissible but still the virus is
able to be neutralized by antibodies
induced by vaccination or by previous
infection
now there is another mutation that is
present in some of the bias of concern
specifically the ones that the lineages
that they started in south africa
having in brazil and they are prevalent
in many areas of the world here in the
united states is more
the uk variant the one that is more
prevalent which is the previous one the
one that contains an invitation
still being able to be neutralized by
the vaccine in case of the eric mutation
if 484k that is more problematic
the the the neutralization drops you can
see here the vaccinated against
against the previous variants they have
very high titus
but they have this with physical vaccine
and then it drops between four to ten
times
as compared to the previous variants
now even though it drops still the
series able to utilize because the
vaccine induces very high tyres of
naturalized antibodies so we think
that these vaccines are gonna and
acquire that's what it seems to be in
the in the
clinical observations that have been
made um
more recently they seem to be also
applications against the variants
although perhaps a little bit less
application is not what it is against
the previous ones but the little bit
less efficiency is still a lot of
cases because these vaccines are
extremely applications for preventing
clinical symptoms with coping
so eric is a little bit more of a
concern especially for people that have
low neutralizing antibodies for whatever
reason
they may actually break immunity a
little bit uh better than what it is
they all the
the other bias
all right so in summary i show you how
an ndv based vector is presence as
constraints in this bottom protection
from virus infection both in lungs and
nodes of hamsters of symptoms
immobilization
two phase one trials started in vietnam
and thailand and respects would also
have
prices in brazil mexico and the united
states and if they saw
good promise then we will move to phase
two phase three trials
um the new variants are still
neutralized by syrah from immunized
individuals but
some at lower tires and that's
underscores the need for
continuing epidemic studies just in case
antivirus acquires still
more changes that make them break in
better immunity that won't they are
doing now with these buyers
this is just to acknowledge um all the
different agencies that have contributed
in funding research in my lab for profit
19
nih nci department of defense the villa
military foundation
uh some private organizations
non-profit like the fundamental the open
philanthropy project
the jbp the abv foundation
thanks a lot for all the support for
these studies
and obviously these studies would have
not been possible without a group of
individuals
that are performing work with copic 19
and here i just want to thank everybody
in
my group that has contributed one thing
or another
to copy 19 studies to this last
year with that
i conclude my presentation thanks a lot
for
visiting